s jean-marie le pen bien le bonsoir dans
quelques minutes nous en revenu sur la
situation politique et loire jours du
deuxième tour
rapidement une ou deux questions sur ce
drame qui provoque pas mal de réactions
ainsi ce communiqué de jacques chirac
qui vient d'être publié qui parle d'un
geste sauvage qui semble être de nature
raciste
cet acte odieux nous rappellent ils font
encore la vigilance qui s'impose devant
toutes les formes de l'intolérance
le socialiste bernard kouchner l'ancien
ministre est encore plus direct
puisqu'il dit que les paroles de jean
marie le pen déclenché la haine et
parfois la mort alors il ressort des
commentaires a fait ce sont là des
déclarations scandaleuses et démagogique
dire responsables politiques au premier
rang desquels je vois qu'il ya monsieur
chirac
personne ne sait rien de cet incident
qui s'est produit hors de ce2 du défilé
de jeanne d'arc
lors du défilé du front national même
pas au même niveau puisque nous étions
au niveau du pont et que ces faits se
sont produits à 150 mètres en amont de
ce pont mais sur les berges et que par
conséquent personne en tous les cas pas
dans la police nommé en poule de
prénationale mais immédiatement
il suffit qu'ils se produisent un
incident pour que des politiciens plus
ou moins véreux fasse des déclarations
anti raciste en espérant que celle-ci
retombe sur notre responsabilité c'est
scandaleux et ça indique bien à nos
concitoyens ce qu'ils devront voter dans
les jours qui viennent d'un mou tout de
même est ce que vous condamnez à
condamner quelque chose que je ne
connais pas je regrette qu'à malheureux
se soit noyé mais dans une agglomération
de 10 millions d'habitants il se produit
des incidents de ce genre sans que nous
soyons directement responsable n'est
obligé de les commenter
même si ce sont des étrangers qui en
sont victimes
est ce que ça sera ma dernière question
est-ce que vous avez des informations
qui vous permette d'assurer que les
skinheads en question n'est pas de ce
puzzle au front national et quand il y a
des skinheads qui tourne autour de notre
manifestation
c'est généralement pour la polluer et
essayer d'attirer l'attention des
journalistes pour essayer de nous faire
porter des responsabilités qui ne sont
pas les nôtres et notre service or
généralement écarte c'est important et
c'est provocateur toute dernière
question est ce que vous avez demandé et
vous même une enquête à votre propre
service d'ordre est ce que vous avez
essayé d'en savoir plus sur ce qui
s'était passé
nous étions avertis par la police qui
s'était produit un incident dramatique
tout à fait en dehors de notre cortège
et a bien précisé que le front national
n'était pas impliqué dans cette affaire
sur laquelle il y avait d'ailleurs une
enquête encore une fois je constate
qu'une fois de plus il y à chaque fois
qu'il ya une grande manifestation du
front national comme par hasard un fait
divers qui y est associée et encore une
fois dans une agglomération de 10
millions d'habitants se forgeant de fait
divers peut toujours se produire ou même
être créés à volonté pour revenir à la
politique et à la préparation du
deuxième tour alors vous avez annoncé ce
matin que vous alliez en quelque sorte
faire durer le suspense puisque vous
allez annoncer votre propre choix
mercredi après avoir entendu le débat
chirac jospin alors est-ce que vous
prononcerait clairement pour hull 1 pour
l'un ou pour l'autre pour le votre blog
pour l'instant ses côtés on me dit qu
danse à la platitude de ce deuxième tour
le débat sera un temps fort et bien je
serai comme mes concitoyens à aller
coûte des deux candidats et puisque gdc
personnellement la liberté de vote à nos
électeurs non sans faire connaître mon
opinion sur l'un et l'autre candidat
j'ai dit que moi j'attendrais ce débat
démocratiquement et je ferai connaître
le lendemain quelle sera ma décision
personnelle mon vote personnel
évidemment je ne puis le préjugé puisque
par définition je le soumets à
l'alternative de ce débat en 88 2 vous
aviez voté blanc sauf erreur oui mais
j'avais demandé que lombard à la route
pas une voix pour françois mitterrand ce
n'est pas le même sens ce n'est pas le
sens de ce que j'ai dit aujourd'hui où
j'ai rappelé à patrouiller à monsieur
chirac que le front national était une
baïonnette et comme disait bonaparte on
peut tout faire avec une baïonnette sauf
s'asseoir dessus
précisément quand vous dites que sira
que c'est jospin empire on peut en
déduire que vous avez donné une petite
préférence pour jospin et que vous avez
qualifié d'homme respectable pour vous
l'avait qualifié d' homme respecté ce
que monsieur jospin n'ayant pas été
premier ministre n'ayant pas été
président de conseil général n'ayant pas
été maire de ville ne s'est pas trouvé
impliqué dans
emma bouille et dans les laits comment
dirais-je les enquêtes qui visent un
certain nombre de gens même y compris
l'un des deux candidats très précisément
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce fameux
débat de demain soit des deux candidats
est ce que vous pensez qu'au tout
dernier moment ils vont infléchir
nettement leurs discours sur
l'immigration par exemple
j'attends une minute de vérité il y a
les hommes politiques ne sont pas des
machines pas du moins je l'espère et au
cours d'un débat
si ce débat à noyal et démocratique ce
qui restera à démontrer et bien
j'attends de la un éclair qui peut
peut-être me m'éclairer c'est le cas de
le dire mais peut-être n'aurais-je rien
à dire parce que peut-être l'un des deux
candidats sortira quant à eux de ceux de
ce débat auquel cas je serai dispensés
d'avoir à faire connaître mon opinion
cela dit on peut dire d'un point de vue
purement cynique et après tout en
politique ça compte que vous préféreriez
peut-être avoir monsieur jospin lisible
parce que ça ouvrirait des perspectives
de proportionnelle pour vous et votre
mouvement oui le ski la porte
nous avons tous évidemment qu'on n'est
pas le leader d'un parti politique sans
penser à son intérêt légitime mais
l'intérêt de la france me préoccupe
beaucoup plus la situation dramatique
dans laquelle se trouve notre pays et
notre peuple m'inquiète infiniment plus
que de savoir si monsieur jospin ou
monsieur chirac seront les futurs
l'interlocuteur du front national mais
l'un d'entre eux ne s'est pas cachée
monsieur chirac de vouloir l'élimination
du front national en resserrant encore
le dispositif majoritaire et en
supprimant la la proportionnelle dans
toutes les élections où elles existent
par conséquent les militants du front
national tous ceux qui pensent à ce
mouvement de la sympathie ils peuvent
être inquiétés par ce genre
d'affirmation et de menaces mais pour la
france je crois malheureusement que l'un
et l'autre de ces candidats ne seront
pas en mesure même s'il avait de la
bonne volonté jeu après tout je ne la
leur mesure pas et pour sortir le pays
du drame de l'immigration du chômage de
l'insécurité de la corruption politique
de la dénatalité du fiscalisme bref je
n'attends rien de cela et je pense que
tout commence demain
et c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé à un
grand rassemblement patriotique un grand
rassemblement du peuple français
j'ai dit le pr nationale ce n'est pas la
droite c'est la patrie c'est le peuple
français c'est la volonté d'établir pour
notre pays une voie de salut et je crois
qu'il ya des élections il ya les
élections municipales
peut-être les élections législatives eh
bien nous serons sur le terrain
merci pour clore ce chapitre ce soir là
pour puisque vous aurez l'occasion d'y
revenir mercredi
je vous propose d'entendre la réaction
des des principaux intéressés après
votre discours de ce matin vous allez
l'entendre rpr et socialistes pour une
fois se rejoignent sur le thème tout ce
qui est excessif est insignifiant